إذا قتلنا 4000 طفل فلسطيني، فأنت
تعلم أن ذلك لم يكن
كافياً وللمصري المرابط
يريد صورتك حسناً اذهب اذهب
لماذا يجب أن أذهب لماذا يجب أن أذهب
أخبرني لماذا يجب أن أذهب أنا أقف
هنا أنا  لدي أمريكي مجاني، إنه
بلد حر ليس مثل
[موسيقى]
مصر
في مصر سوف تحصل على والديك، هل يحب
والدك أظافره، سوف يقومون
بإخراجها واحدًا تلو الآخر، هذا
الرجل الذي
يتمتع بتاريخ الخدمة هذا داخل
حكومة الولايات المتحدة التي تعمل على
وجه التحديد على العلاقات مع
الشرق الأوسط تشعر أن
[موسيقى]
طريقة [
موسيقى]
[موسيقى]
أنك لا تتحدث الإنجليزية، إنه أمر سيء للغاية ولهذا
السبب تبيع الطعام في
بطاقة لأنك "  إذا كنت جاهلاً ولكن
يجب أن تتعلم اللغة الإنجليزية، فسوف يساعدك ذلك
بالطبع عندما يقومون بترحيلك إلى
مصر ويريدون إجراء مقابلة معك
لكونك